think about how to manage perceptions of
your peers of your clients of your
colleagues of your supervisors you need
to become good at perception management
and of course in most situations there
will be quite a tight relationship
between your performance and the
perception that is getting created but
this is not always the case right and
you hear this all the time that people
complain that someone else took the
credit for his or her work this is in
the end what it always comes down to
perception is reality and of course then
also the question whose perception just
the perception of your team lead is this
the only person who knows about what you
did or does the senior leader know about
you as well it has also this perception
that yes this person in this team is a
high performer this is a rock star